[Applause]
in psychology it's actually called
confidence competence loop that the more
competent confident you are yeah yeah
the more confident
the more competent you are at something
right the more confident you are yeah
yeah
and because you're more confident you're
going to do that activity more confident
and then you're going to get more
confident and yeah yeah create momentum
right oh that's a great confident
confidence loop and and so yeah that
that when you're
confident it leads to greater confidence
when your competence leads to greater
confidence so most people right now are
going
okay well where the [ __ ] did you get the
confidence to switch it
yeah like once you got the confidence
yeah run with it great let's go to the
top how do you start the loop
especially when you're at your lowest
yeah i was at my lowest for a good uh
decade and a half every single day okay
you know with with this label i would
struggle
you know have anxiety and all these kind
of issues and now i was introverted
just personally but because of my issues
i became very shy
and chai is different introvert right
introvert is just you know you like
being by yourself you're replenished by
yourself
um are you an introvert or extrovert no
but uh
it's interesting that you make that
distinction because there are people
that they just don't need the validation
of strange
strangers constantly so we look at them
we're like oh you're shy
and they're like no i'm full yeah i
don't have the void you have
so i don't need you to tell me i'm great
all the time i'll just speak when i want
to speak
where there's performers probably like
me and many other comics and people in
other fields as well
where we're like i don't feel whole yeah
am i funny am i whole yeah yeah am i
funny in my heart we're good okay now
i'm whole
i got a couple breaths of oxygen as my
buddy neil brennan puts it and i can be
good for now so that's interesting to
make that distinction that's right
shy is different than introverted yeah
shy is almost like a self-imposed
introversion
you don't want to be you want to be
friendly you want to have these other
people in your life that like you spend
time with you want to speak out loud you
just don't have the [ __ ] confidence
to do it
oof yeah yeah that i mean you do you
think
performers a lot of them come from
feeling not enough and they that's what
has to do with them too it must yeah
yeah it must i mean like
i don't think it's uh i i think on some
level that's where like the
um that's maybe the catalyst yeah you
know like that maybe is the spark like
not getting enough attention in some way
there's also just a love for it i don't
think every comic has to have this like
tragic story
you know oh this this person was touched
as a kid or his parents hated him or
these type of thing like i think there
are people who just
truly enjoy entertaining you know and uh
but
it is odd to stand in front of people
and just go
aren't i good you know
but my my relationship with it has
always been
kind of um before i had a crowd that
like we all knew what we were
getting in on when we came to the show
before i had that experience
i was almost a little bit resentful of
the audience who would be like all right
make me laugh and i'd be like
who the [ __ ] are you like this is you
signed up for this too
right right right you wanted to be made
laugh and i want to make you laugh you
don't got to cross the arms
prove to me you're good at being an
audience too so it's cool to be at this
stage i don't want to distract too much
so shy and introverted yeah and so i
think it's sometimes
it's a choice i i i was very depleted i
didn't have that
you know uh there's a a great book
called quiet and it's a power of
introverts and by susan kane
and she has uh this idea that
uh introverts wake up and they have five
gold coins
and every single time they engage with
somebody somebody takes their coin
and they feel depleted so then they have
to be by themselves to replenish
extroverts wake up and they have no gold
coins
and every single time they engage with
somebody they get energy and energy and
energy
and uh so i i could feel that and on top
of it being damaged i felt like i was
shy
i wanted to be able to even though i was
shrinking and being visible
i didn't want to be seen i didn't want
to be seen right we all want to be heard
we want to be recognized
and so it wasn't and but i've always had
that drive because i had purpose because
i wanted to
you know i don't know maybe just deep
down i felt like there was something
there and i just couldn't figure it out
i guess what i'm asking is like the
person that's listening right now and
they go
wow i'd like to make that change in my
life what was the first
step what is the easiest thing to flip
in the positive direction
so my my inspiration was my desperation
right
i was so desperate and what i would my
advice for somebody in that same
situation
is to take a small simple step right i
believe that you don't have to do little
that little things add up to big things
yeah right little by little don't lose
400 pounds exactly
exactly little by little a little
becomes a lot
yes consistency compounds and i would
say that for greater confidence
first of all i think confidence is not
something we have because we always say
oh i want to have confidence but i think
that's also a way of brainwashing
ourselves
because i don't think we have these
things i think we do there's certain
things you could do
that will give you confidence like right
now if everyone did this exercise
and said on a scale of zero to ten you
know how confident do you feel about
something right and and or just about
life in general
yeah and people could say it's a five
then you could do a thought experiment
game you could gamify you're like okay
well what do i need to do to feel a six
yeah or a seven yeah right maybe i need
to play some some you know good music
maybe i need to just get up and you know
move around or whatever it happens to be
yeah um and i would say do something
small get yourself out of your comfort
zone
there's this quote everyone says isn't
there a matt damon movie about um
buying a zoo right whatever but there's
a quote saying that
you know 20 seconds of like you know
insane confidence or courage could just
change your life yeah and i would i
would
i would say that oh here's one then
while the beauty is in the butterfly
the growth happens in the cocoon right
it's the struggle to come out that
builds your strength
to be able to soar you said something
last night about like uh it was inside
versus outside
yeah like i was i was using the metaphor
of an egg that oh yeah yeah
if an egg is broken by an outside force
life ends but if an egg is broken by an
inside force
life begins so great things begin on the
inside so what is that
first thing like yeah even what is the
smallest little thing that you would
recommend first step so i would make
your [ __ ] bed
yeah i would say that fear right because
usually what makes us not confident
is uncertainty right it's the it's the
unknown and it's not comfortable
and while the comfort zone is a nice
place to visit
nothing nothing grows there right and
you know this right to get on stage to
be able to you are where you are because
you put in the work and the sacrifice
yeah and those late nights and those
gigs that you know and this that you
didn't want to you know do and you know
and so that's what success is
you know most people see the tip of the
iceberg and they see this lifestyle
and yet below the iceberg is that
discipline and
all the things that led to it the mess
and everything so i would say
ask yourself this question what is the
tiniest action i could take that will
give me progress towards this goal
where i can't fail so make it so
minuscule so maybe if people aren't
confident about their body
and they don't work out maybe working
out an hour a day is way too big
so a small simple step put on your
running shoes you know maybe
reading we said leaders are readers and
try to read a book a week but
you know breaking it down it's about 45
minutes for the average reader a day
which is a lot but if you that's why we
triple people's reading speech so they
can do it in 15 minutes a day
but me 45 minutes is too big maybe a
small simple step opening up the book
reading one line some people don't floss
their teeth right
get your get get yourself the floss one
tooth because you're not going to stop
at one tooth
and you develop some kind of momentum
right so that's really the key
start with one tooth it yes
and metaphorically for whatever you feel
fearful of right you know take that
small simple step
break it down where you where it's
digestible well before i don't want to
take up too much of your time and you're
very busy man but
we got to get through fast yeah yeah
yeah so f is forget
forget about what you know about it so
you can learn something new because if
you go to an event
about sales and starting a business you
might think you know it then you're not
going to learn anything new
also forget about distractions because
multitasking
is a myth right it's actually task
switching so when you say you're
multitasking nobody is actually doing
that
you're going from one task to another to
another and what it costs you
is time yeah because it could take five
ten minutes to regain your focus like
you hop onto social media like you just
that's that's like a wormhole
and you come back and you're like oh my
god just 30 minutes just disappeared
because you could scroll till you die
right that's never going to end ever
ever right so do one thing i was the
worst when instagram used to tell you
when there was nothing left
right man i sucked today
i reached the end there's no more [ __ ]
so here's the thing so um so i would say
forget about distractions because you
lose time
yeah you make mistakes when you're
trying to multitask so
if you're want to study something and
learn it you're listening to a podcast
you're taking note but if you're trying
if you're on slack and social media and
traveling you're not going to do
anything well you're going to make more
mistakes
and the third thing you use up more
energy you burn more brain glucose so if
you suffer from mental fatigue
which a lot of people do brain fog
sometimes it's because you're trying to
multitask and you have too many tabs in
your computer open
and even if they're minimized they're
still taking up energy right
they're still taking a memory right so
kind of close that tab something comes
in your mind
something you have to do write it down
so you can release it right because what
you resist
persists if you try not to think do
something you're just gonna do it more
right yeah yeah so forget about those
things the a in fast
you got to be active like because
learning like life is not a spectator
sport and so many people
take they sit back passively and say
okay
you know teach me but that's not how the
brain learn the brain doesn't learn
through consumption
it learns through creation and you can't
learn by just being lectured to
and a teacher is not it's not the
responsibility to push information in
your head
and so as much as you get active so for
example how can people be active
i i mentioned the first thing just
taking some notes right
and actually handwriting notes and
digitally taking notes is different
right and so i don't know and people
could could mention this i recall
handwritten way better yeah and
handwritten
and then you're not you're not using
that you're not alone and i'll tell you
one of the reasons
digital is great for uh storing
information yeah
sharing it you know but handwriting
notes has been proven to help your
comprehension and retention
one of the reasons why is most people
could type pretty fast
and you could type almost everything
that i'm we're talking about right now
but you can't possibly hand write
and so it forces time with it it forces
you to reflect on it
to filter it what's most important and
relevant here
right so those are little things plus
you're it's very kinesthetic and
personal when you're handwriting things
you're also going shorthand so you're
just
writing the important words yeah it's
super
dense exactly you take notes handwritten
much better you know even a whole brain
note-taking way
is because the reason why you take notes
is because there's a learning curve
there's also a forgetting curve you do
know how much is lost
and when you listen to a podcast read a
book get a lecture
at university after hearing it once
after two days how much do you think you
forget
on average i don't know 25
30 80 percent isn't that wild
listen to something you got to keep
putting out the same apps every week
we're working too hard
so by taking notes it helps that to
reduce that
yeah and a fun way of taking notes that
will help your comprehension retention
take a piece of paper put a line right
down the page
on the left side capture on the right
side create
now this is nuance on the left side
you're going to
take notes on the right side you're
going to make notes
these are the things that are being said
these are my thoughts about it exactly
that's great so that's a left and right
brain away so left brain is usually
logic and linear so you're going to
capture how to remember names right uh
what's the morning routine right and
you're capturing it
on the right side if you're if your mind
your imagination is going to go
somewhere
let it go instead of distracting a mind
wander let it go on the right side of
the page
yeah how am i going to use this how does
this relate to what i know what
questions do you know just go on and on
and you create the future belongs to the
creators right
i love being around creatives because
like you know where jobs are going
they're being
automated they're going to machines ai
but what's not
is our ability to create and imagine
that's what is limitless